look at the size of that fun
someone get that man some glass says
holy [ __ ]
oh that's the funniest bit of this is
that it grow the
[ __ ] up bro get glasses my dude holy
34 ipads plus a condom from the bank
what these things these are the actual
witchcraft where does that go
why do that whoa where does it go
underneath these no it's sorry it's
witchcraft it's witchcraft
what it's respect where does it come
from
where did he go where did it go oh my
god witchcraft i believe in witchcraft
now thank you tiktok
hey we've entered the indiana tick tock
at last
here it is i'm so excited
iphone wow iphone
they say so little but still so much
iphone do you understand the complex
nuances of this
don't judge it otherwise follow if you
have an iphone
iphone say iphone oh wow iphone
wow iphone
iphone
wow i went somewheres automatically
yeah basically all i gotta do is
challenge them to a thumb war
they say yes and then
you know oh oh no what happened
oh my god oh my god oh my god
how does that's a deal i want to play
anymore i believe in witchcraft now
no i don't want to put i'm gonna go near
that thing getting the hell away from me
we're gonna oh god and power of this
thing
is unimaginable dude if he like works
that thumb out to be
really strong you've seen the fingers of
climbers right they're thick as hell
imagine the power and mag
he's got a knife and weapon on him at
all times it gets confiscated at the
airport
guys check out what this hotel i'm
staying in has a real wake-up call
guaranteed that's so cool ass man making
videos on a children's app no job you're
single
you live with your parents what are you
even i'm glad someone finally
said it because it's so it a lot of it
is very serious guys
check out this thing it's a playstation
controller but if you zoom in on it
it still has the pattern of the
playstation symbols
follow for more tech talk some
interesting information
grown ass man no job guys check this out
i just thought it was wholesome
well done this lady she is so glamorous
i just wonder who she is so maybe i'll
say hello
excuse me i just wanted to say you look
absolutely amazing
yes she does
[Music]
i get a bit bullied sometimes oh you get
bullied
you look bloody beautiful
you're the most beautiful woman in
islington isn't she
what does she look like
and look at those wristbands trendy babe
oh you've got marilyn there marilyn
monroe there
you've got lows
who bullied this woman hey show yourself
now
how dare you die [ __ ] how could you
bully everyone
i'll get four sometimes
no it's not funny
but it's also kind of yeah i saw this
my mind is this thing i thought it
sucked at first
i've been doing this wrong the whole
time
how do you
i thought you used this attachment just
like this this method
this is like four how much expensive is
it yeah it's [ __ ] 400
right how do you not know how to use it
how do you not know it's purpose
it's like the most expensive curler you
can buy i don't get it
oh she even had this one i mean i guess
i'm not one to talk i
barely know how to function this camera
and microphone you know what i retract
this
three ways to kill yourself without
feeling any pain all right here we go
[Music]
spit it out yet because you
tell me yet come on what are they
serious is there part two
one really right
so cringe it's beautiful when you record
your white friends saying
i'm not
[Music]
it's a good thing i never said the v
word otherwise i'd be in big trouble
can't imagine what twitter would do to
me if i said
[Laughter]
they need this i don't know how but my
car has it so that
it doesn't fit if you put a diesel one
it just like doesn't open
and i don't know how it works but why
does every goddamn car not have this
we you know when we shot the my car
video to part two we had to be taken
down
we had to gas up the car that we were
promoting
and we asked them twice is it petrol
or is it diesel and they said petrol
it was promo for a car right and we
shoot the video and then all of a sudden
smoke comes out of the engine because
clearly it was
diesel and we were like oh that's funny
actually like that will make the video
cooler and epic because [ __ ] smokes
is coming out of the car and they're
like no
that that's bad for the car so we can't
show them like
you said bedrock by the big dog
stupid idiot i'm gonna make you take the
video down
oh god out of this [ __ ] you actually are
this is a forbidden life hack that a lot
of people are starting to use
when you put them in your shoes you will
notice a huge difference so this is
before the size up insoles are in the
shoes
now get ready for the difference i
promise you this is ridiculous
so this is the after the best thing what
about your betas needing salt in their
shoes how how did that end up in my
feeder
click away on that one that's dumb
okay here we go here's construction
people living on the moon
there's already a breakaway civilization
there we've been there for a very long
time
and a few whistleblowers have come
forward and said that the people on mars
i'm one of those whistleblowers and i'm
ready to come forward there's people in
mars gates
and the moon for a long time now was it
mars
the ancient egyptians governments are so
advanced now they used to be 50 years
ahead of us
you know exist now they're about 300
years ahead of us in the last 10 years
over 200 nasa scientists
dead strange they got thanos snapped
it's the same dude is this posting like
what is this
you can't just put on a suit and a good
camera and be like
guys uh mars people dead
uh nasa advanced um
when you're given links africa three
years in a row
happy birthday christian ronaldo happy
birthday
oh he looks ecstatic look at him
oh he's never been this happy oh a
thumbs up
love biscuit i'll use that that's good
if i ever get a present that i really
like and i want to show people that i
like it
thank you for this wonderful gift of a
lens cap
you know what words aren't even
necessary clearly
[Music]
hell yeah all about that
eat it eat him he can fit
eat him
[Music]
[Laughter]
did he eat him or not i need to know
part two part two
part two please what are those called
chubacabras
chicarabas chavochumbus
come on dude dream big you can eat it
what's your background bro are you in
heaven uh
maybe somewhere close to jason what's
your background
i'm in my room i'm too happy for this uh
too high well you're about to get that
looks so similar too what's going on
[Music]
you're high as [ __ ] flute jesus shows up
what do you do
great tick tock very good oh [ __ ] i
think you're still alive
bro i know i i swear i've seen this
video oh my god it might live
have i reacted to this i see
oh [ __ ] it gets me every time i know it
gets me
every time oh my god it might live
this throws a bottle of water on him
why did you leave the us to move to
london and i just tell them
i mean this way it's amazing it's just
it's so good beautiful and it's always
changing
sometimes it's a different shade of gray
i mean the gray tones it's just like how
could you not it's so
tempting world's lowest shield
by henry cavill apparently
can you edit me inside as well
i want corpse to do it i need course on
this one am i
better than everyone
i hate this i hate this so much it's
really nice to read outside
okay i hate how it's associated with
like oh you're reading outside you feel
the need to
show everyone you're no it's just nice
okay i'm so sorry i want to sit outside
i had no idea this was a thing you know
what go read outside
yeah there's nothing wrong with it i'm
breaking this dumbass idea
actually one time i read outside and
this old man came up to me
and he was like this is so nice finally
some young people not on the phone and i
was like hell yeah gee
i am better than you i am better than
everyone on their phone
yes you know what thank you how's the
war going for you guys
i can't wait to go back home and see my
mom
oh he was just about to send home next
day
who's gonna tell jerry's mom bro look at
this [ __ ]
snow oh [ __ ]
oh my shoe
one no oh no
you're dead ass right now he's just
going on an adventure
she was like this is my chance yo i'm
going to read outside
she can't stop me
someone tip this man please
i want to wear this it looks so fun
hypnotizing i love it
hell yeah all right the highest sheesh
smash like on this video subscribe new
video tomorrow
but oh actually guys we have restarted
tsuki go to tuki dark market
go to basic click on that beautiful
man's face
and buy all of it that's it bye bye